what's going on Alan dragu here L copy
goat and today I'm going to explain
three copyrighting Frameworks that you
can use to write ads emails video hooks
whatever it is that you want if you
write copy you can use these anywhere
anytime in fact there are a ton more
than just three copyrighting Frameworks
but these are my tried and true used
forever all the time Frameworks that
have been used by Legends like Gary Bena
Gary Halper John Carlton Ben settle
Kevin Rogers and all these cats have
been using these Frameworks forever so
I'm going to explain them to you break
them down as easily and simply as I
possibly can so you can watch this video
and start making your copy instantly
better but before we dive into that it
would mean the world to me if you hit
the like button on this video and hit
subscribe to this channel that'll tell
me that hey you really like the content
that I'm putting out and you want me to
continue putting out more free content
just like this on YouTube for you every
single week and I'm going to continue to
do that so I appreciate it I appreciate
the support thank you so much stick
around to the end I have a gift for you
so let's Dive Right In all right I've
got my handy dandy iPad and this
beautiful dock that I have whipped
together which by the way if you want
this doc that I am going through to
explain these Frameworks it's in the
description below you just pop in the
description hit the link drop your email
tell me where to send it and I'll send
it right over to you ASAP all right so
let's Dive Right In the first
copyrighting framework that I want to
explain is Ada okay so Ada was made
famous really by jary Halper who was the
highest paid copywriter alive in the 80s
90s all the way till the lower 2000s
when he passed away in 2007 he was
really competing with Gary beninga as
the highest paid copywriter but nobody's
going to take the throne as one of the
greats and he uh used Ada in almost all
of his sales letters including the code
of arm sales letter that we are going to
break down today which was his highest
paid and most famous sales letter but
Ada in its simplest form is an acronym
for attention interest desire action
okay that's what a means and the goal of
ADA is to grab their attention keep them
interested keep the reader interested
make them want it whatever your product
is and tell them what to do
simple as that no over complicating okay
grab their attention keep them
interested make them want it tell them
what to do now let me give you some
examples of what that looks like so it
can come to life for you example number
one this is Gary halpert's coat of arms
okay it's some Snippets out of his sales
order so I'm going to show you exactly
how him the legend the goat of ADA used
to use Ada throughout his sales letter
okay and then I'll show you some
practical examples of how it be used in
context today on platforms like Twitter
and Linkedin and stuff like that so A
for attention dear friend what you are
about to read is the most exciting and
unusual letter you have received okay
that officially has my attention because
he's telling me what I'm about to read
is the most exciting and unusual I love
those power words there exciting unusual
that you have received okay it doesn't
tell me who it's for he doesn't make me
a promise he doesn't tell me he's gonna
sell me something he doesn't do any of
that because the first line of ADA is
attention your job is to solely grab as
much attention as you possibly can
that's it and if you grab the attention
then they'll read the second line that's
the goal of your first line and in a the
attention part is usually the headline
so you get a big ball headline in the
code of arms letter there was no
headline it was just the first line okay
so it was just it looked like a plain
old letter but in this sense the
headline there is the dear friend what
you're about to read is the most
exciting and unusual letter you have
received that is the Grabber where
everybody who's reading that should be
like oh okay and you keep going now
interest is where you increase you peque
their interest to continue read again
the goal of the first sign is to get
them to read the second the goal of the
second line is to get them to read the
third the goal of the third line is to
get them to read the fourth and if they
they read four lines they'll probably
read everything that you wrote so that's
why Ada is so powerful now moving on to
interest it's about an opportunity to
own something that has never been
offered before a work of art that is
unique to your family name okay now this
is where it gets really interesting no
pun intent for the interest side it now
starts to make it about them you now
start to hone in on your target audience
and I'll give you an even better example
uh in the next one but in this one he's
now talking about the reader so he's got
the reader attention I want to you know
I want you to read this unusual exciting
letter it's kind of generalistic it
doesn't give me much but then interest
is like a a work of art about my family
okay so if you're interested in that
sort of thing well I've now piqued your
interest to a new level my family work
of art if you're not interested in that
sort of thing you'll likely bounce off
at this and that's fine because at this
point we're trying to get high quality
people to continue reading what we have
to offer so now you had their attention
you increase their interest now you need
to increase their desire you have to
make them want what you are about to
show them your product your service your
offer okay so we said it's a work of art
that's unique to your family name next
is desire imagine owning a beautiful
coat of arms Custom Design just for your
family
based on historical research picture
framed on your wall a symbol of your
family's Legacy and distinction you read
this and your desire increases okay you
learned what it was a second ago work of
art that's unique to me and then it
increases desire this beautiful he he
puts an image in your head where you're
like okay now I'm imagining it on the
wall above the mantle the fire's going
people come by the house and they say
what's that and I say oh let me show you
you my sophistication I look smart I get
to talk to people he's making me desire
it okay so I'm reading this I my
family's Legacy my distinction okay all
these things are now running and then
the action obviously is a longer letter
than just these four lines but towards
the end he says to get a personalized
family code of arms fill out the
enclosed form and mail it
today act quickly this offer is only
available for a limited time okay so in
this he says EX exactly what to do next
there's no guessing Okay fill out the
enclosed form step by step like
literally like fill out this form mail
it today okay like that's that's the
exact thing you need to tell your people
what to do next okay you got their
attention you got them interested you
increased their desire and now they need
to take action now that is direct
response copyrighting so that's our
first example the next next example is
one that I wrote and this was a tweet it
was a thread uh that went pretty viral
for me and so it was really really
simple so attention is my kids aren't
going to college this will grab a lot of
people's attention because it
contradicts Society okay so most people
my most people want their kids to go to
college they talk about college as being
some kind of high society it's hilarious
any of these things and so now I've
captured a lot of people's attention
because I said
I said something contradictory to what
the typical person thinks my kids should
go to I want my kids to go to college
but here's me as a dad saying my kids
aren't going to college okay so I've
captured your attention huh what's this
guy thinking and then I say interest
instead of wasting four years of a
college degree instead of wasting four
years of degree typo I am going to teach
them copyrighting I like this because
it's emotionally driven instead of
wasting for years to here's what I'm
doing I'm emotionally driving the people
that did go to college and they're like
wasted just I I didn't waste my time my
money so now now some people feel like
oh you know they got that emotional
attenion and they say and and I'm
creating a new narrative I say instead
of wasting a degree I'm going to teach
them copyrighting so I'm creating this
interest that copyrighting might be more
valuable than a 4-year degree so if
you're interested in not wasting your
life going to college or you're might be
interested in copyrighting you're
interested in a track for your life you
now I have your attention and I have
your interest I've increased that okay
next is desire now I'm going to make
them want to desire my product
copyrighting I teach copyrighting I'm
going to make them desire they'll be
making six figures working 4 hours a day
without driving to an without ever
driving to an office or working for a
boss now I've increased the desire of
copyrighting itself I've stated lots of
benefits to understanding copyrighting
to which you don't get from college okay
coming out the gate you're you're going
to be making six figures a year college
can't promise you that okay not even
close sometimes maybe depending on your
agree but very unlikely working 4 hours
a day that's half the time that most
people on this earth work without ever
driving to an office yeah good luck
College promising that or working for a
boss I just created benefit benefit
benefit benefit benefit so their desire
is like oh my God how do I learn this
copyrighting thing and then I lead him
read this to see how you can do the same
and then I write a nice little article
LinkedIn thread whatever that gets them
to get more information to which I plug
my email list plug my product sell them
something all because I used a so the
hook was there attention interest desire
action that was a really really good one
next up here's a great one from Justin
Welsh on Twitter this was a Twitter
thread that he did attention today my
little one person business crossed 7.5
million in total revenue whoa that is
really interesting because one person
business Crossing 7.5 million in Revenue
that's insane you have my interest
especially if I'm a business guy an
entrepreneur honestly if I'm just Joe
schal on the street I'm like how did
this guy do that next is the interest it
took 1,712 days specificity I reain zero
ads huh and operate at about 9 1% margin
you officially have my interest because
not only did you cross 75 million or 7.5
million you did it in almost like record
time that's like 5 years 6 years
whatever it is with zero ads and you
make way more profit than 90% of the
people I know so now not only were you
interested in him just making that much
money you were interested in how the
heck did he do it with those
stipulations those constraints and then
you create the desire he creates the
desire for them to keep reading here are
the 22 steps of my wild and strange
Journey well at that point that's all I
want to do is know those 22 steps and of
course the action read this threat so
very I mean you literally have to put
that in there as if it wasn't enough to
have everything you literally have to
say read this thread and people will tap
and scroll and read That's how simple it
is so that's Ada okay super simple
attention interest desire action you can
use it for LinkedIn Twitter you can use
it for email where a the a the attention
is is the subject line and then you
start writing the email with interest
desire action keep going right you could
use it anywhere sales letters showed you
plenty of examples so that is goat mode
let's keep going to my next one and that
is Bab all right bab stands for before
after Bridge that's bab and what you do
with bab is you picture the problem you
picture the solution and then you show
them how to get there so it's kind of
like hey here's where you are today
here's where you want to be
here's the map to get there that's bab
and that's why bab is so powerful
because bab is a
transformative version of copyrighting
and everybody has a problem they want to
transform whether it's their body they
want a sixpack it's their money they
want more money okay whether it's their
career it's their sleep it's their
health it's their sex life it's their
family life whatever it is everybody has
some sort of part of their life that
they're trying to transform and so you
need to find out what is the biggest
problem my reader has that I have solved
and how did I solve it then you can use
bab all day long to show them how to do
it for yourself so bab stands for
before after Bridge Okay so before the
transformation after the transformation
The Bridge on how you got there let me
give you some examples example one is
one that I wrote this one took off I
wrote this one on Twitter and it and it
blew up and it actually sold a lot of
product for me uh before 12 months ago I
was a horrible writer okay so a lot of
people have that problem where they're
like I'm just a bad writer or I suck at
writing right 12 months ago I was a
horrible writer after today I a number
one best-selling author huge
transformation I went from horrible
writer to best-selling author in a year
like people are like how did you do that
that's the first question how did you do
that that's how you know bab works
really really well when you make them
think how in the world did you do that
because your next line is you tell them
how they did that here are five tips to
help you become a better writer
instantly so they'll see that and
they'll be like yes I got to listen to
this guy I mean he was if few went from
horrible writer to number one
bestselling author yes I want his
writing tips because I want to be a
better writer so great example super
simple and then from there I give him
five tips usually in the form of an
article or a thread or something I plug
my email list at the bottom or I plug
the product that um will help them even
further if they really really like that
this one I I'm 99% sure um I plugged my
email Emil list that email list drove
him to a product and that product sold a
ton so I usually almost always go for
email list by the way let me give you
another example I used to weigh
287 lb okay that's a big problem that a
lot of people have especially in America
overweight obese they want to lose
weight now I have a shredded six-pack
and weigh 180 lb so you lost 107 lb and
you are God Shred the guy reading this
or the gal reading this is probably like
I wish I wish right that's that's what
you want to do you want to tweak the
emotion oh my gosh what a transformation
I wish I could have and then the bridge
here are the only five workouts you'll
ever need to know coming from that
transformation you now have the
authority to command whatever it is
about nutrition or diet or exercise or
whatever at this point and then of
course it's a thread that leads to your
email list or your product okay almost
always email list last one last one of
bab and then I'll give you the last
formula framework so Bab this one is 6
months ago my email list was less than a
100 people okay so my ideal reader right
here is a copywriter somebody building
their brand building their email list
yes I have a small email list too oh man
I wish I could have more and then after
today I have 2,000 obsessed copywriters
who read my daily email oh my gosh how
did you get 2,000 people and six how did
this guy do that and then the bridge
here's the exact framework work I used
to explode my email list so very simple
before after Bridge okay so what's the
problem that your ideal reader has right
has today how did you solve it insert
your solution super simple incredibly
viral you could steal that all day long
next let's go and talk about one of my
actually these are all three my favorite
they're all so good but before I do
another round on Pas again please like
And subscribe to the channel if this is
really really valuable to you it means
the world to me now I'll continue making
content like this okay let's keep going
p a s call out the problem make it worse
give them a way out that's what Pas is
for it stands for problem agitate
solution okay so you need to call out
the problem hey do you have this problem
make it worse cuz sometimes when people
have a problem they're lukewarm about it
okay they're not really trying to solve
it they're like H it's
okay you know they're just kind of
flying by the seat of their pants no
problem make it worse where you agitate
the problem where where you try and make
them know it's actually worse than you
think it is okay it instills fear it
increases emotion and they're like I
need to solve this don't do this
manipulatively okay that's not what I'm
saying what I'm saying is increase the
emotion because they genuinely need to
solve this and maybe they're not taking
it serious enough especially when your
product is really good okay we're not
trying to manipulate people we're here
to help them and then we give them a way
out so problem agitation solution let me
give you an example do you sleep less
than 7 hours a night a lot of people
probably be
like yeah they don't think it's a big
problem and then they read the next line
every night you do that you corrode your
brain and reduce your lifespan
drastically oh my gosh are you serious
like you know you agitated the problem
that they sleep less than 7 hours a
night it wasn't a big problem before now
it's a big problem because I just told
them you're corroding your brain and
your lifespan is D drastically reduced
so now they're like oh my gosh and then
you give them the solution here are 10
tips to help you sleep eight plus hours
every night they're going to read that
immediately cuz they're like oh I need
this I need this immediately so that's a
big one right there next one I didn't
write this I just want to clarify but I
think I thought this was really good is
AI stealing your copyrighting clients
that's a problem some people are like AI
Ste I think it's so funny I'm just like
dude just ride better than AI That's a
great like problem people are like yes
yeah like my client is like us it I got
fired blah blah blah any agitate AI is
only getting better making it harder and
harder for you to compete that's where
you're like oh my God I'm swim I'm never
going to get a client again this is bad
this is bad for me and then it goes to
the solution instead here are 10 prompts
10 AI prompts your clients don't know oh
I love that that's a great line right
there that will make you look like a
genius where you're like oh man they're
going to hire me to start doing even
better work and I could use AI to my
advantage and all these things and blah
blah blah so that's a great line you
call out a problem you agitate it you
make it worse and then you prompt the
solution last one last one on Pas and
that'll wrap up all of our Frameworks
problem do you sit in a chair all day
long yes oh my gosh sit 7even eight
hours a day all this stuff sitting is
the number one cause of back pain that
often leads to thousands of dollars in
medication and surgery oh my gosh I'm
just a normal office guy going to my 9
to5 you're telling me I'm going to be
spending thousands on medication and
surgery this is insane right so now
you've agitated the problem okay exactly
how we teach here are three dead simple
ways to fix your back pain almost
instantly I love the almost great
constraint instantly hits into the
desire really really good so that wraps
us up with Ada bab and PAs my three
favorite copyrighting Frameworks that
you can use for ads emails anything that
you want if this was helpful go to Allen
dru.com subscribe to my email list and
I'm going to give you a free gift I'm
going to give you copyrighting Catalyst
68 cash cow copyrighting tips that you
can read in 90 seconds or less each tip
and enjoy learn you'll profit from it
you'll enjoy it a ton you'll be a better
copywriter because it and again thank
you for the support it means the world
to me I will continue making these
videos for you till next time catch you
you can watch another
video I got tons of them you could just
click the next link what do you want to
learn I mean I've
got so much
content are you still not subscribed
what's wrong with you I do this for free
I mean just just
subscribe thank you
thank you for doing that
[Music]